does Reggie Miller have a cheesy enough
poster when he was playing and I see the
Reggie Miller boom poster this was 1995
it's just not cheesy enough his red
joins us now Reggie needed to cheese it
up you got to go back a little bit
I want the down that's Holly look up
right now I did a milk commercial in my
spot built shoes
I believe my rookie year that was it
would make that wall 1987-88 I believe
Polly it was a milk commercial poster
full length with my shorty shorts and my
high socks I believe in my spot built
shoes when spot built was still relevant
I only don't think they make shoes
anything anymore but look that up okay
tell me if that's cheesy enough for the
wall all right
paulie's gonna look for that we were
talking about great scores the great
scores of all time and you know
depending on which conference Don McLean
is the all-time leading scorer in the
pac-12 right so correct yeah were you
close and at UCLA okay which there's a
lot yeah well if you're the all-time
pac-12 score you'll are going to be the
number one scorer at UCLA true but think
about some of the great players that
have come out of UCLA obviously yeah yes
yeah but I'll send or only played he
played three years correct yeah
or he'd be the old sign leanings
remember freshmen weren't eligible to
play when they were freshmen yeah there
was a freshman team
how was tyler hansbrough the all-time
leading scorer in the ACC history played
four years I know but you would think
guys who played and played three years
or guys who did play four years would
have scored more than Tyler Hansbrough
uh not necessarily I mean when you think
of the ACC you would think oh my
goodness easy Michael Jordan Michael
Jordan only played three years and you
went a great score wait it wasn't a
great score yeah
people would being James Worthy or JJ
Redick JJ Redick is up there though
right yeah yeah I think up there yeah I
think he's where is Redick on that
all-time
scoring list I think he's second second
to tyler hansbrough
who was the best scorer you ever faced
in college in college it would probably
be hmm
Walter berry from st. John's the truth a
truth yeah they they had mark Walter
berry Chris Mullin they were stacked
coach Lou from Saint John's you can see
why the rivalry between them and
Georgetown was relevant they they were
stacked but the truth Walter berry would
give you number Paulie did you find the
picture of reg it is a as
non-threatening as any basketball
posters ever been it's ready in short
shorts medium like socks drinking up
it's gonna make it yeah we got okay yeah
talking about but you don't look
threatening at all don't I look like I'm
13 years old I swear I have not even
reached puberty yet in that poster they
should have Photoshop some muscles in
there red come on man I look like a
string bean that is so sad how did the
paces ever draft me I'm like are you
serious I played 18 years in the
Association that's a sad picture there
really if if I was just going on looks
and I profiled you I'm thinking that guy
may not last rookie camp
no no I'm surprised to this day I was I
was petrified coming in the training
camp number one I was a late sign II so
I didn't get to start training camp with
everyone else I was about 9 to 10 days
late I'm coming with Chuck person
Steve Japan a [ __ ] wayman tisdale Vern
Fleming John long I mean these guys
veterans established and here I come 165
pounds from the west coast which
everyone thought the you know basketball
was soft on the
coast I'm going to Indiana and I'm late
to training camp and dr. Jack Ramsay God
rest his soul the Hall of Fame coach the
prerequisite is everyone had to do a
mile and was under a certain time guards
had to do it under a certain time for
words and sinners and that was my whole
thing I wanted to win the guard
challenge of all you know even though I
was gonna be late I was gonna win
because that's one thing I knew I could
do I could run the mile I could I was
going to beat the time and Lord and
behold Vern Fleming ran circles around
me in that damn mile uh it was a bumpy
start but thank God those guys they they
accepted me and my quartz and the rest
is history
Reggie will be on the call with Kevin
Harlan it'll be this Thursday night he's
got the Bucks and the Warriors 10:30
Eastern on TNT the player on the floor
that you would like to have no matter
what the price for the next five years
in the Bucks Warriors game would be for
the next five years I mean look the easy
call would be auntie takubo because he's
younger than Stefan and KD but it
wouldn't be by a lot
I just don't think we've seen players
and we're gonna do on this Thursday a
boxing analogy and I like a boxing tell
of a tape between Kevin Durant and Yanis
because we haven't seen two players at
basically 7 feet the wingspan do the
things that they're capable of doing of
controlling a game the rebounds the
defense the block shots the length one
dribble from the three-point line being
able to finish the only thing that's
holding to me Yanis back from reaching
KD stature is KT is a lethal shooter he
is a born killer scorer
I think Yanis is evolving into that but
I don't at this point still in his
career I don't think he trusted his shot
yet it's coming under coach Budenholzer
in that system because they love to jack
three
I think he's becoming more comfortable
with it but I don't think he trusts is
it in a sense where when teams and
defense sag off of him he likes to make
up the difference and try to get an
easier shot as opposed to just settling
for 18 to 20 footer he'll try to get a
you know 13 to 15 footer because it's an
easier shot for him yeah I agree that
that's sort of holding him back having
that you know go-to shot go-to jumper he
said you know usually trying to take it
to the hoop Oh once he gets that down as
the greatest bow time listen to what I'm
saying if he ever got like a George
Tucker Jordan have a great jump shot his
rookie year maybe his first two years
when he did get that he was unstoppable
Yanis will become unstoppable if he gets
a consistent jump shot there's no way
you'll be able to stop this kid what
about the way what about Ben Simmons if
Ben Simmons gets a jumper I would put
him in that category as well but Jana
this is freaky
athletic Ben doesn't have the
athleticism he's athletic but he doesn't
have that kind of athleticism yeah where
you could spin and you know throw him
off balance
and still finish there's no one like you
honest there's just no one like him
katie is close is the Katie can score
and he doesn't have he doesn't have the
muscles I mean this dude's look like a
Greek god no you scream Greek god he's a
Greek freak yeah yeah yeah hey something
happened last night with the Denver game
Kyrie Irving was all upset that Jamal
Murray was taking a three as time
expired because he wanted to get to the
50 point mark
Kyrie grabs the ball throws it into the
stands he has a problem with Jamal
Murray after the game basically saying
you know it's a punk move to do that
your thoughts on Kyrie Irving being
upset that Jamal Murray is trying to go
for 50 well my uncle drew castmate he
allowed me to be in his movie I
appreciate that
but you weren't you upset when he got
you say weren't you upset what do you
have 48 weren't you upset when he got 40
this vid probably will be his
career-high of all time 48 and I have no
problem with him trying to go for 50
well why didn't you stop him when he got
38 why didn't you try to stop him when
he got 42 you can't be upset I mean it's
your getting paid you should be
embarrassed if anything she should be
embarrassed
Jamal Murray dropped 48 on the league is
best different the Celtics have the
league's best defense crazy a great deep
great team defense yeah and you got
scorched at home by 48 and then Jamal
Murray's not a bad player but 48 you
know where 48 and I think that was more
frustration but I have no problem with
the kid going trying to get 50 because
he'll probably never be in that
situation ever again so why not try to
get it against the league's best defense
the Golden State warrior with the best
chance of breaking Kobe Bryant single
game record of 81 yeah that means they
got to play four quarters and that's the
problem
you gotta cuz that means it's going to
have to be a close game yeah i would
probably say Steph because he'll get a
high volume of threes and he can have
one of those nights but the other night
reg if it's you know he was in the zone
and let's say it's a close game how many
of you think clay would have had the
other night give him the way he was
shooting and he doesn't mean how many he
would have he would had 18 threes
probably and probably would have
finished with at least 70 points because
Kobe played 42 minutes that night
against Toronto mm-hmm that close game
that benefit benefits you it's almost
like Kobe kind of wanted to keep it a
little bit close they were down they
able to come back for the Lakers in that
game it wasn't like they were up and it
was almost like a comeback so all three
of them
Durant curry Thompson they all could
probably go for 80 but they would have
to play for
quarters which is highly unlikely given
the scenario with all three of those
guys I don't see I don't see any of them
catching 81 Magic Johnson gave Luke
Walton the dreaded vote of confidence
does Luke Walton last the season
Reggie Miller yeah yes I think it would
be premature it was magic in palanca
that went to him before the season even
started said don't worry about a slow
start so I don't know how the reversing
course now we all knew that they were
going to have these struggles it doesn't
bode well when you go into Portland and
win a big game that you haven't won in
16 tries and then come back the next
night and get stomped at home with a
koalas Toronto Raptors that's not a good
look if you're Luke Walton but you've
got to give this you've got to give them
a leash and understand the struggles
that's going to happen when you've got
LeBron James and a bunch of young
hard-working guys but they don't know
how to win so you're gonna have your EDS
inflows ups and downs well it takes time
to learn how to coach LeBron and how to
play with LeBron and that's what I I
think the detriment of the Lakers is
going to be when management front office
starts to get nervous and say we got to
make changes or we got to keep up we got
to be a playoff team we got to be a top
four seat like you this is a feeling out
season and has to be viewed that way and
if it's not I think you do something
that you're gonna regret I agree with
everything you said number one Laker
fans you're not going to be a top four
seed this year so allow the growth to
happen I would put the Lakers and Luke
Walton maybe on the clock next year how
they how they finish this year they've
got to make the playoffs I will say this
if they don't make the playoffs I could
see them making the change but they
should make the playoffs and then
whomever they bring in because you have
to bring in another free agent next
summer that's when the Lakers are on the
clock that's when you can't get off to
slow starts that's when the scrutiny for
magic or raw polenka for Luke Walton for
LeBron James to me it all starts next
season this is this is supposed to be a
feel-good we
we got the biggest fish in free agency
this past summer to go with these young
guns let's see what happens we should
make the playoff and we should be a it'd
be a win if we get to the second round
it'd be a win it's a stretch but it
would be a win and leave it at that
now the clock starts ticking on whoever
you can bring in to pair with Leblon and
going forward that's when everyone needs
to start looking at being on the clock
and looking like what's the what's the
next move yeah I just I do bran usually
gets his guy magic didn't bring in Luke
Walton and it just feels like he might
be the fall guy here but I go back to
when LeBron went to Miami and people
wondered if Erik Spoelstra was gonna be
able to keep that job and remember that
all the Brawn doesn't respect Erik
Spoelstra you know Spoelstra is still
coaching there I don't know that's what
yes you know why because you had strong
management and Pat Riley that Riley was
running things and I trust me
Pat Riley was like LeBron you get along
with Erik Spoelstra because he is our
coats he is not going anywhere so you
make it work that vote of confidence
wasn't given to David Blatt and they
moved on to tyloo and they ended up
winning the championship there yeah but
it's magic gonna do that to LeBron about
Luke Walton I I hope I hope not because
number one Luke is proving himself
especially as a player he wanted
championship a few championships under
Riley and you want a champ or under Phil
Jackson and then as a coach associate
head coach with the Golden State worse
he should be given a long leash but if
Pat Riley does this for Erik Spoelstra
to LeBron why does it magic do this for
Luke Walton to LeBron and say hey he's
our guy
maybe maybe magic needs to be told by
LeBron hey he's our guy or you know
let's back off it who is to say that
magic has not given behind closed doors
Luke Walton that long leash just because
they met doesn't mean that it's the end
of the rope for Luke Walton how does
that get out if there's two guys in the
room
you get outraged I don't know and it got
out for a reason again Luke should be
given a longer leash than what he's
given right now no one is surprised by
the Lakers start and where they are
right now look they're only a game game
and a half out of the eighth spot and
what did I tell you everyone between 2 &
9 are going to beat one another up
there's only one outlier in this league
and especially in the Western Conference
and that's the Golden State Warriors as
though we did say and I did say the
different Nuggets were the second-best
team at nine and one and they're the
only team to beat Golden State yeah III
think they're our top four team in the
West absolutely
I think Denver Denver's especially when
you play there as you well know you know
that's a great home court advantage to
be playing in that outfit and we saw
last night everyone was saying the
Celtics are the best team in the east
and Jamal Murray put up 48 on the best
defensive team currently in the
Association reg will be on the call with
Kevin Harlan that's Thursday night it's
Bucks Boyer's that'll be at 10:30
Eastern on TNT safe travels we'll see
you next week in Los Angeles I cannot
wait I am so excited to come in and hang
with my dad and with you Theodore
that'll be exact one for that hour yeah
that'll be great that'll be great I'm
bringing draymond Green in - really no
no no I'm not gonna do this okay all
right
who would I bring in that you'd have a
problem with okay about the old days
[Laughter]
okay that's a problem okay but we're not
gonna do that because it's there's no
it's a feel-good moment to have you in
studio with kinder gentler Reggie you
know and it might be UCLA day I think
Maurice jones-drew
so I could have you know you at 6 7 and
mojo at 5-4 that's stress you need to
say he's 5 4
people are gonna go Kevin Hart is in
studio oh good
Mugsy I was only kidding of course you
were all right safe travels tell Harlan
we said allo and I'll see you next week
thank you for your doughnut that's
Reggie Aloysius Miller for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]